la hemofilia es un rasgo recesivo ligado
al cromosoma x que afecta a la
coagulación de la sangre si alguien
tiene hemofilia su sangre no se coagula
fácilmente si una mujer portadora y un
hombre hemofílico tienen una hija cuál
es el porcentaje de probabilidad de que
ella es decir su hija tenga hemofilia
si se sienten inspirados los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo e intentan
resolverlo ustedes primero vamos a
resolver para eso pensemos en los
genotipos de la madre y del padre
empecemos con la madre como estamos
hablando de un rasgo recesivo ligado al
cromosoma x estaremos trabajando con el
cromosoma x recordemos que como la madre
es hembra tiene dos cromosomas x y el
padre tiene un cromosoma x y un
cromosoma
pero ahora pensemos en la hemofilia aquí
nos dicen que la mujer exportador
entonces decir que la mujer es portadora
significa que uno de sus dos cromosomas
contiene el alelo de la hemofilia y el
otro cromosoma no portador implica que
ella no muestra síntomas de ese rasgo no
tiene hemofilia pero porta uno de esos
alelos recesivos de la hemofilia
entonces podemos decir que uno de sus
cromosomas x no tiene hemofilia usaré la
letra h mayúscula para identificar el
alelo dominante y esto quiere decir que
no hay en móvil
generalmente utilizamos la letra
mayúscula para el dominante y la letra h
minúscula nos ayuda a indicar que el
cromosoma x tiene el alelo de la
hemofilia la h minúscula simboliza que
es un rasgo recesivo entonces aquí si
hay presencia de hemofilia pero qué pasa
con el padre bueno como es un rasgo
ligado al cromosoma x pero el padre
solamente tiene un cromosoma x y como
nos dicen que es un hombre hemofílico
entonces este cromosoma x tiene
el alelo de la hemofilia la razón por la
que él tiene hemofilia es porque aquí no
hay otro cromosoma x con el alelo
dominante que pueda dominar a este alelo
de la hemofilia pero ahora combinamos
estas dos situaciones en el cuadro de
pune vamos a ver para su hijo el padre
puede contribuir con el cromosoma x que
tiene el alelo de la hemofilia o con el
cromosoma jr mientras que la madre puede
contribuir con el cromosoma x que no
tiene el alelo de la hemofilia o el
cromosoma x que contiene el alelo de la
hemofilia vamos a dibujar el cuadro de
pune ahí está entonces cuáles serían los
diferentes casos
bueno el cuadro superior izquierdo sería
el cromosoma x de la madre que no tiene
el alelo de la hemofilia y el cromosoma
x del padre que contiene el alelo de la
hemofilia por otro lado este cuadro
sería el cromosoma x de la madre con el
alelo de la hemofilia y el cromosoma x
del padre con el alelo de la hemofilia
bien ahora este cuadro sería el
cromosoma x de la madre que no tiene el
alelo de la hemofilia y el cromosoma del
padre finalmente éste sería el cromosoma
x de la madre que porta el alelo de la
hemofilia y el cromosoma del padre y nos
preguntan cuál es el porcentaje de
probabilidad de que la hija tenga
hemofilia entonces cuál de estos casos
nos muestra a la hija bueno
las hijas serán los casos en donde
tengamos x x estos son los dos casos en
los que podrían tener una hija estos dos
no porque como tienen un cromosoma y
significa que tendrían un hijo así que
dentro de estos dos casos en los que
tienen una hija en este caso tenemos dos
alelos recesivos así que esta es una
situación en donde tienen una hija con
hemofilia entonces si tienen una hija
cuál es el porcentaje de probabilidad de
que sea hemofilia
bueno como la probabilidad es uno de
cada dos podemos decir que existe un 50
por ciento de probabilidad lo más sutil
del cuadro de túnez es que podemos
contestar todo tipo de preguntas por
ejemplo si nos preguntamos cuál es el
porcentaje de probabilidad de que tengan
un hijo hemofílico podemos ver que uno
de estos cuatro casos corresponde a un
hijo hemofílico por lo tanto existe un
25% de probabilidad de que tengan un
hijo hemofílico y de forma similar
existe un 25 por ciento de probabilidad
de que tengan un hijo no hemofílico si
alguien dijera cuál es el porcentaje de
probabilidad de que tengan un
descendiente hemofílico bueno eso
corresponde a estos dos casos entonces
como dos de los cuatro casos
corresponden a un descendiente
hemofílico eso corresponde al 50% de
probabilidad
por otra parte suponiendo que tuvieron
un hijo cuál es el porcentaje de
probabilidad de que no tenga hemofilia
bueno en este caso podemos decir que
como tuvieron un hijo pueden suceder
estos dos escenarios pero solamente en
uno el hijo no tiene hemofilia así que
nuevamente la probabilidad desde el 50%
espero que esto les haya sido útil nos
vemos en otro vídeo